تقع في غابات بالي ، هناك
قرية صغيرة مختلفة قليلاً
عن الباقي
[موسيقى]
في منطقة بنك الله ، هناك
جين متنحي شائع بين
السكان يتسبب في معدل أعلى بكثير
من الصمم ينتقل
عبر سبعة أجيال من السكان
ثلاثة آلاف ثلاثة في عمود واحد
يموتون بنسبة 44٪ في بلدة يبلغ عدد سكانها 3000
شخصًا ، عادةً ما يولد أربعة أو خمسة أشخاص فقط
صمًا مما يجعل
نسبة سكان الصم فريدة بشكل لا يصدق من
أن لغة الإشارة الخاصة بهم باللغة البنغالية
يجب أن تعرف أن لغة الإشارة هذه معروفة
فقط لـ  أهل بنك الله
لأنه تم إنشاؤه من قبلهم ، فهو يختلف
عن أي لغة إشارة أخرى في جميع
أنحاء العالم ، وقد تكيف كل جزء من المدينة
مع جيرانهم المقتولين ، ويتحدث العمدة
سكوت أكولا ، ويتحدث المزارعون كاتا
كولوك ، ويتحدث المعلمون كاتا كولوك
[موسيقى]
[  الموسيقى]
في Bangala أعتقد أنها فريدة جدًا
لأن السمع والموت يعيشان معًا
بدون تمييز وأنا سعيد جدًا
بالبقاء هنا الآن ، ثم يمكنني ذلك  لديك
عائلة صم في مجتمعها لأنهم
مميزون بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى]